[Music]
gotcha yes
gotcha buddy submitted by tomahawk steak
yeah police uncovered an identity theft
ring after two men failed to pay a seven
dollar Waffle House tab
why does a Waffle House come to Southern
California because I think Southern
Californians with [ __ ] on Waffle House I
love it though we're also Waffle House
has this connotation of being cheap and
like delicious for truckers you know
driving through pit stops and that's
like that's all we have any love I don't
know why Danny's to still around to be
honest and he's a [ __ ] service this is
that late night drunk [ __ ]
that's why you expensive though for that
garbage the awful house it makes me
happy and the menus a lot smaller to us
it's like they specialize in just
exactly what they insert like it tastes
homey or at least though one time I
tried well California the problem
California is the fact that I feel like
everyone here is to help conscience to
accept something like Waffle House I
will say Denny's no they have something
called it used to be called The Midnight
Slam and it was a promotional thing but
it got so popular they left it on the
menu it's a hamburger patty with
hashbrowns fried egg bacon cheese slam
not the Grand Slam it's like some it's
just like a Grand Slam inside a [ __ ]
burger
have you ever ordered the moons over my
hammy that's the classic dude I've never
ordered it oh and read it and I go what
a funny authorities in Louisiana they
discovered this identity theft ring that
was based in LA oh yeah my identity so
the Waffle House employees they caught
police saying that two men had stiffed
the restaurant and they just left
without paying the seven dollar bills
come on and then they said that these
two men they were in a u-haul and that
they took off in the you ha that's when
the cops are looking near the location
or where the Waffle House was for this
van and then they finally found it
parked out in you're right hotel they
approached the van the passenger he
actually ran into the woods and he fled
but then they
hot the driver and then the police dog
ended up catching the one that fled and
then once they open the u-haul van they
found a whole bunch of fake ID IDs and
credit cards and credit card skimming
devices and also the Waffle House
receipts that they didn't pay get the
[ __ ] receive who are these people
so these two men 18 and 20 years old
they were the ones responsible for all
this but there it was all traced back to
LA they started in LA yeah so they're
saying that it's a base in LA that they
were just there just road tripping damn
what an adventure there's Waffle House
have Fried Chicken I don't know that's
the thing about this whole time I think
they have a country fried steak have you
been to a Waffle House never been - Oh
awesome
it's one of those things where I think
if you're a local they're like I want to
go there but then for us like we don't
have it so it's like gold online Zippy's
you could also get like a dollar 29
waffles and then you could add chocolate
chips and strawberries yup that sounds
[ __ ] delicious dude they always ask
you whatever you order would you like a
waffle with it
hell yeah yeah I hope the ice wall was
yeah I live like a whole month because I
was in North Carolina when I was in the
Marines whoo and there's a Waffle House
there and I love that place well I was
the only Asian guy everyone was also
trucker or some fat lady behind the
counter there's always a nice fat lady
behind the counter then did she call you
sugar
as well yes good morning sugar she
called me sugar chinks
good morning [ __ ] puffs always pay
your bills
cuz you don't want to get caught yeah so
identity theft is kind of wrong but can
you imagine being 18 and 19 and you and
your friend are just like yo that's road
trip well they're saying that
investigators are working with the
Secret Service to see if there's even
bigger a bigger ring that they're like
they're the [ __ ]
there's like a real real yeah Oh cuz if
they stole that much [ __ ] they should be
a lot more ballin than that maybe
they're just getting a cut mmm
I feel like if you get arrested and
taken down by a police dog you would
feel like such a [ __ ] please dog yeah
why cuz
got caught by police dog yeah so I feel
like if you got your ass beat and then
the cop arrested you Snyder to the floor
when you go and retell that story oh
yeah you're like I'm not I was this guy
he was like six three slammed me on the
ground and it's like all that you took
on a man but then when like a furry
animal I bite you and it took you down
like you can't this there's no bragging
rights you can't even tell your friends
you don't think that animals more
ferocious though like more scary I guess
oh but when you tell people yeah [ __ ]
yeah bye okay I will tell you this dog
if I was a cop though I would make sure
that my drug sniffing dog is a
pomeranian [ __ ] cred from that Dib
then what happened this [ __ ]
Pomeranian got into this [ __ ] little
fluff ball just bit off my shirt like ah
you know or Winnetka I know I got
stupidest [ __ ] [ __ ] though I do not
miss that dog at all wait she's gone Oh
could you brother move yeah my best my
dad's favorite [ __ ] dog now I think
he likes the damaged ones the most cuz
they're like projects for him yeah and
that dog is just [ __ ] annoying his
[ __ ] he's like biting all the other dogs
now too I bet you're his favorite son I
am NOT actually thanks Ari
yes these guys are both arrested on
charges of identity theft bank fraud
monetary instrument abuse and theft by
fraud and there were additional charges
against one of the guys including
criminal damage to property driving with
a suspended license fraudulently
acquiring credit cards and forgeries
they're just [ __ ] fraudulent across
the floor because they were installing
these credit card skimming devices and
gas stations how do they do that they
just go into the where they we pump the
gas yeah I've been seeing a lot of
articles with dammit I always pump gas
like that you gotta be careful like when
you look at the credit card machine some
of them are Wiggly
hey what's the look for 7th looked into
it shake it right no it's like there's
something somehow where you can tell
that it's a skimming device I have to
look it up yeah cuz I'm so on autopilot
it just goes like you're always on autos
swiping around no I'm usually like alert
but though as soon as I see a cloud
machine I'm like this is awesome you
guys seen our house right I'm right
outside our house there's like these
little public benches so we were sitting
right by the public benches with tight
this huge ash [ __ ] stroller and I'm
waving at him because I'm like all cool
we're outside we're not really outside
like with this boy or whatever he didn't
see us and then he gets out of his car
and me my mom and like Tyco we're all
looking at him and he doesn't see us at
all and like we want like I could have
just like jumped in the title of like
really real daddy yeah like he didn't at
all and he was like we were probably
like this far apart I'm like what the
[ __ ] I could kill him right now and you
would never know because I missed you
guys so much I wanted to go straight
into the house so I was in the zone
house I'm gonna go inside and see my
family so you're on high alert all the
time except for when you're around
that's my home so I shut off high alert
because I'm already in my home but your
job as a father and as a husband is to
protect the home and you're already
shutting it off yeah cuz I have a gun on
me that doesn't sound like a very good
idea I'm shutting off my high alert
have you seen those compilation videos
of dads being super dads where they
catch their yeah that's probably not
gonna be you in there
like the baseball bat he just ball
blocks it yeah like laying on the couch
and the kid crawls and like falls off
these like whoa and he just catches his
head I feel like all the baby chem the
baby's gonna fall Bart's gonna look
around maybe the reason why the kids
getting [ __ ] smash no I already
called my five times it was just a one
time he didn't know right now I'm
looking up how to spot these credit card
skimming device and and they're just
saying the smell is [ __ ] for you to
check for tempering when you approach an
ATM check for obvious signs of tampering
like near the speakers the screen the
card readers if there's any wire
sticking out look [ __ ] up all the time
you know what I'm saying like if any
graphics are not aligned or like if
you're at a bank and then check the
other ATMs to make sure that they all
look up there's so much checking to do
now
and anything like wiggle everything like
just push that what I'm really gonna do
though I know every single [ __ ] gas
station right before a pump all right
[ __ ] turd bucket like car with the
wiring come on dude it's so much
technology stick with game up no I will
say this though because I swipe so much
with cars and stuff and I really don't
care to cash on me unless any like like
street tacos ya know did you see those
Chase Bank [ __ ] machine shits no no
do the extra high [ __ ] tech you don't
even need to talk to anybody what are
you talking about what do you do
ATM the ATM machines they're super
[ __ ] high-tech what's high-tech
you've never had to talk to anyone on
thirty years
stuff like that you have to specifically
do with a teller before it's like they
virtually eliminated that whole thing
the only time you need to go to a bank
till to see if you have a very very
specific issue so before that you would
have a certain limit like you could only
deposit roughly about 3 grand or
something you can go as high as like 15
grand now that's true yeah so it's like
they've almost eliminated the human
interaction or you could probably 15
checks in at once it just goes yeah but
it's like super high-tech it's crazy
never really said anything that hasn't
already been happy yeah what is it when
you're a kid when the ATM hall opened
did you ever were you ever tempted to
stick a house it looks scary then you
can here go Clank did I just describe a
regular ATM machines for automated
teller machine yeah so it's like what a
teller can do the ATM how come you guys
don't tell me things again mirrors from
the future you can see people behind you
crazy did you deposit from your phone
well how about this how about this
[ __ ] but you guys didn't know about
this there's this big outside where I
put my kid and it takes me we don't even
[ __ ] turn a key
yeah touch the Stewart in the [ __ ]
hands you went backwards all you look
for my Tesla to element oh that's not
you do you think he has to start a fire
and then boil water and the waters
powered locomotive later I just picture
myself doing this now you guys ready for
a picture sit still for 45 minutes and
in the [ __ ] life almost boof gonna
explode oh my god
[Music]